Since nearly the beginning of human history, maps have shaped the world we live in...
...and marked important milestones in our advancement.
Cavemen drew maps to help remember where to hunt and gather.
Expert cartographers charted maps...
...to help explorers navigate little-known places and define borders.
Scientists mapped space to help mankind reach the moon.
Today's digital maps are more sophisticated but some things haven't changed.
Our maps still help us get to where we want to go,...
...guide us when we're lost, and perhaps most importantly,...
...give individuals the ability to change the world.
In 2005, Rebecca Moore used Google Earth...
...to illustrate the impact of a planned development...
...and convinced her community to come up with a better alternative.
From this effort, Google Earth Outreach was born...
...in order to give anyone the tools to change the world with maps.
Since then, different people in organizations...
...have been creating real, long-lasting social change using these tools.
Their maps help to protect the environment,...
...provide better crisis response,...
...improve safety and save lives,...
...and even preserve a culture.
Through Google Earth Outreach, these organizations are using digital mapping tools...
...to write their own chapter in history.
Google Earth Outreach.
How will you use maps to change the world?